i checked this out weeks ago for a bit
of like reading
this is light just when we thought the
wizarding world of harry potter
couldn't get any stranger it turns out
that some of the wildest details and
craziest characters
never even made it onto the page that's
right so many unbelievable story lines
distant family members magical creatures
and hogwarts dramas
were cut out of the books before they
ever made it to print
while jk rowling is confident she made
the right choice it's amazing to think
about how different harry potter could
have been
if only she'd left these details in
you're harry potter
i'm hermione granger back when she was
first writing the books
jk rowling had originally planned to
give hermione a little sister
the unnamed granger sister was going to
have magic abilities and was set to
arrive at hogwarts a couple of years
after hermione
but according to rowling she just
completely forgot to add her in
when the goblet of fire came out she
said i always planned that hermione
would have a younger sister but she's
never made an appearance and somehow
it feels like it might be too late now
what a shame we would have loved to meet
the youngest granger child
though who knows what she would have
been like one thing we're not sure the
fans could have
ever forgiven rolling for is definitely
the elimination of
ron weasley he's going to sacrifice
himself
no you can't there must be another way
while jk was writing the series
she found herself in what she describes
as a bad place and actually toyed with
the idea of ron losing his life
everything's gone wrong so this one good
thing in my life will now go wrong as
well
but luckily she knew deep down that she
never could rupert grant said he was
really nervous to read the last book to
find out whether or not his character
was going to make it until the end
but also that he was up for ron not
surviving the final fight
as if fred and lupin weren't enough to
an outside observer it would appear that
jk rowling has
a particular vendetta against the
weasleys as at one time she planned for
mr weasley to be taken out as well
he almost didn't survive the vicious
nagini attack from the order of the
phoenix which
rowling considered doing in order to
amplify the fear of lord voldemort
thankfully for us and the weasley family
she couldn't go through with it so mr
harry potter
without whom i would not be here draco
malfoy is definitely one of the most
iconic names in the harry potter
universe but it wasn't always this way
i think my name is funny g malfoy comes
from the french phrase
mal foie meaning bad faith which suits
the entire family perfectly
but before jk landed on it draco's last
name was going to be
spongin spongin draco spongin
no one is striking fear into the hearts
of their enemies with the last name like
spongin that's for sure somehow it's
even worse than hermione's original last
name which was
puckle pleasure we wouldn't exactly call
anyone that malfoy hangs out with his
friends yet for a brief moment he almost
did have a real one
rowling created a character named
theodore knott who was supposed to
become good friends with malfoy
as both of their families were prominent
death eaters she even wrote a scene in
which theodore's father went to visit
lucius malfoy at their home and the two
boys sat outside and talked about harry
and dumbledore
you think there's someone here who's
worse than dumbledore harry potter
it's really a shame that that scene was
cut out as it would have been a
really interesting way to see malfoy on
his own in the goblet of fire
jk rowling almost included a weasley
family member who really stuck out from
the rest
red hair and a hand-me-down robe you
must be a weasley
she wanted to introduce ron's cousin
miffalda who would have been sorted into
slytherin
yep she was going to be a troublesome
kid and the total opposite of the rest
of the weasley family
rowling even planned for her to become a
match for hermione academically
and become her rival how cool would it
have been to see that rivalry unfold
i don't think you're a waste of space
thanks
while it is hard to root for dudley
dursley he and harry did make amends
eventually
after dudley went on to have children of
his own but for a brief moment
jk rowling almost gave him a very ironic
challenge
a magical son of his own the plan didn't
last long however as the idea was put to
rest and rowling decided that any late
and wizarding jeans would never
survive uncle vernon's dna my parents
are dentists
is that a dangerous profession one boy
did bite my father once
originally hermione's parents were going
to be a hugely important part of harry
potter and the philosopher's stone
in early drafts of the book rowling had
lily and james potter living on an
island
and the granger family living nearby on
the shore when voldemort attacked the
family
mr granger was to be the first to hear
the screams before jumping in his
rowboat and trying to save the family
he was actually supposed to be the one
who discovered baby harry
instead of hagrid in the goblet of fire
jk rowling originally intended to
include a character named
mopsy who is obsessed with dogs because
who isn't mobsy would unknowingly take
in serious black in his animal form
thinking he was a stray dog the tail i
could live with
but the fleas according to rolling she
didn't add anything to the plot and it
was
far more tragic for sirius to have lived
for years in caves instead of with mopsy
vampires were briefly touched on in the
harry potter books but
never really explored but that could
have been different if rowling had stuck
to her original idea and included a
vampire teacher at hogwarts named
professor troker
ultimately choker was cut because as
rowling said
the vampire myth has been exploited so
many times in literature and on film i
felt there was little i could add to the
tradition
which makes a good point dean thomas was
a regular supporting character in harry
potter but according to one chapter from
the chamber of secrets that was cut out
he was supposed to play a way bigger
part i didn't know you could do that
in this mysterious chapter rolling
revealed that thomas was raised by his
mother and stepfather who were both
muggles
after his wizard father left and never
told him about his powers
but as it turns out his father actually
met his fate at the hands of death
eaters when he refused to join them
back in the philosopher's stone jk
rowling almost included a character who
might have changed everything
if she hadn't cut him out mopsys a blind
wizard
with extremely powerful divination
abilities unfortunately because he was
so powerful
he would have predicted voldemort's
attack and the boy who lived
would never have become a thing she
didn't get rid of him entirely however
as she gave
many of mopsys traits to maddai moody
and of course
professor trolani together we should
cast ourselves into the future
in the chamber of secrets nearly
headless nick was supposed to get to
sing a ballad telling the grisly tale of
how he became
nearly headless how can you be nearly
headless like this
and even though rowling said it was a
wrench to cut it she decided it was not
important to the plot the song can be
found online however
and has tons of gruesome details about
what happened on that fateful day
i read something rather odd about a bit
of rare magic
it's called horcrux we all know the
story of the seven horcruxes and how tom
riddle was obsessed
with using the founders items in order
to store parts of his soul
the only ones he could get his hands on
were ravenclaw's diadem
slytherin's locket and hufflepuff's
golden chalice
according to jk rowling the chalice was
originally going to be a cauldron
but because that would have been way
bigger and much harder to lug around
and then destroy she changed it the
final words of the original harry potter
series make up
one short comforting phrase paul was
well
but originally growling was intent that
the last word would be
scar which made sense but all of that
changed as she was writing the final
chapters
rowling had said that she really wanted
a very
concrete statement that harry won and
that the scar
although it's still there is now just a
scar
it's the best i can do it's how i always
planned it to end
it's crazy to think how different the
books would have been if jk rowling had
left in all these strange details
we're the most curious about mafalda
weasley and her rivalry with hermione
what about you